foreign
there was some history there's some
history in the past couple of years of
that happening of people's smart sex
toys
being hacked intense sexual love
in some sense and that's why I like it
it you know in what sense it is easy I
think it's really unfortunate that
people use porn as a source of sex
education as a performer it's pure
fantasy
foreign
[Music]
I think that what we're really talking
about is an idea of agency
um hey I know we keep looking backwards
but we've all moved on from Freud and
even from some of his descendants
hopefully and B when we are talking
about sex all of the acts whether this
oral sex anal sex group sex all of those
things have existed since Antiquity so
we're not suddenly coming to Liberation
we are returning to the idea that humans
own their bodies that can choose what to
do with them with each other
because fundamentally the idea of sexual
Liberation was really us breaking away
from Victorian era norms and beyond that
constructed a false cage of
respectability for women to sit in for
the most part and then said oh well you
know we liked hiding our dirt but now we
we want it to be public again but also
we're uncomfortable with breaking away
from these Norms the largest amount of
porn produced in the Victorian era
included all of the acts that Freud said
were deserving and unnecessary perhaps
he was just a prude but the rest of us
can make a choice every day in every way
for what we want to do because sexual
agency is what matters not the false
construct of Liberation or repression I
can't repress Olivia I think well you're
kind of fresh me well I have to say
something really important because you
keep saying oh my goodness I came back
we've grown up we've grown up I think
they were so much wiser two and a half
thousand and I disagree what they said
was that pleasure pleasure including
sexual pleasure was practically the
opposite of genuine happiness
and I think happiness is what we're
losing now we don't know how to be happy
we think it's to do with with sex and
pleasure or eating it's not it's what we
hear are you doing no it's about even
making a garden or bring out a family or
singing or making a picture it's about
it's about playing a piano really well
it in fact real happiness involves a lot
of unhappiness because you struggle it's
doing what we human beings do best
no that's Survival that's not nothing to
do with happiness or any other emotions
let's go for this Olivia humans
absolutely can choose what makes them
happy on an individual and a structural
level without it necessarily being tied
to sex or lack thereof upsets you may or
may not approve of the fact that some
people both enjoy sex and Gardens but
that really has nothing to do with
anyone else
foreign
[Music]
this is harmony
Harmony is motionless from the neck down
she's just a doll from the neck down
from the head up she has some
animatronics so she can move her face
she can smile and turn her head slightly
and blink
and she speaks she has an artificial
intelligence personality
that's interesting it's a standalone
personality so you don't have to have
her in the personality integrated into
the doll you can carry it around with
you on your phone or your tablet
and have conversations with her but it's
essentially just a quite a sophisticated
chatbot so sex robots have been in the
headlines for a while but then that's
the only one that's good out there so
what's what's all the fuss been about
well this one on the left this True
Companion that's what they say it's
going to look like on the top left this
is what it actually looked like when it
was unveiled at a trade show there is a
big difference
this one is particularly interesting
because this has been on the headlines
for years and yet no one's ever seen one
other than that model now the guy who
makes him says that he's got thousands
of orders but we've never seen anyone
admit that they've got one and in that
kind of community you'd usually hear
someone talk about it so I'm a little
skeptical about whether or not this
exists
don't think it really does
um in the top left a top right sorry is
um a manufacturer an engineer called
Sergey Santos who has invented a sex
robot called Samantha Samantha's been in
the news because
um it was reported a few months ago that
she was mauled was the word that was
used at a trade show
and there are lots of headlines about
this this sex robot has been attacked
sexually assaulted raped at a trade show
uh I thought this sounded a bit weird so
I dug into that story and then I talked
to surgery as well and essentially what
happened was he put the the robot on
display at a trade show and said to
people yeah of course you know go ahead
have have touch it's a delicate object
and so people did they went and touched
and groped it wasn't a sexual act
um and of course it did get damaged but
not to the extent the newspaper has made
it out to be
Samantha's an interesting robot uh he
built her he didn't start he's not
interested in what the doll looks like
he's interested in the in the mechanics
and the AI behind it so he just used a
sex doll's body he inserted sensors and
pressure points so that you could touch
squeeze that's him squeezing the arm
um and she would respond and he was
quite interested in trying to work up a
consensual relationship in that you had
to approach her in certain ways in order
for her to respond so if you
um if you went straight for the breasts
for example there wouldn't be much
reaction you had to start by stroking
and touching arms and things like that
so it's quite an interesting concept
and then we have Harmony that I just
show you the pictures of the real doll
version and if I can play this video
please this is this is harmony I think
we're going to hear her voice here
unfortunately
um but you'll see some of the facial
movements
and it's actually fairly subtle I mean
she's not gonna pass for human at all
um but it's a pretty subtle thing
she also has a really soft Scottish
accent which is really really strange
when you're in the middle of a hot call
the California Sunshine looking at these
things
um
so
Harmony was released and alongside
another model called Solana recently and
they're also within the past two weeks a
male version has been featured from real
doll on the cover of New York Magazine
um
so the interesting thing is why are they
all in this form what is this about this
this hypersexualized female form of the
sex dolls because I think that's really
quite unimaginative and it doesn't
really reflect the way robotics in
general is going and it comes with a
whole host of problems ethical issues
legal issues all sorts of things that I
think we can avoid by doing a very
simple thing
foreign
[Music]
I think that we're all probably on this
panel agreed that the sort of technology
that people are afraid of something that
fully mimics a human woman Allah the the
cult classic Cherry 2000 is not only a
long way off it's it's not in many many
generations lifetimes from ours the what
Computing would have to be able to do so
we can we can kind of take that idea and
set it aside because we do have robots
the turnback flips and we have robots
that went to chess these are not the
same robots and also their intelligence
is not generalizable my washing machine
cannot also cook my rice it can't take
what it's learned about by wash and
apply that to another problem which is
great news but quite recently I saw a
take in the press that was actually
saying sex robots will be great because
they will replace sex workers and then
no woman has to be abused as a sex
worker again obviously I have problems
with this as a former sex worker when
you think about uh sorry my cultural
touchstones for things like this are
Star Trek the Next Generation we had Mr
Data who could physically make he looked
humanoid he could physically mate with a
lot of different species but he really
couldn't give you pillow talk and if
it's just the act of getting somebody to
reach orgasm that constituted what sex
work is and what sex is I would not have
been that effective an escort because it
would just be people turning up they
want the chat they want the human
interaction when you look at things like
they're absolutely horrible but the
review boards for escorts the most
cutting thing that a client can say
about an escort is that she was robotic
that would kill your career overnight so
it's only ever going to be a minority of
people the love doll people who want a
Fleshlight that talks to them
but if what we're talking about is just
reaching orgasm in a way you know women
have been bridging this Gap with
hitachis and Imagination for years but
that does very much depend on our own
imagination being involved and and
really to kind of assume otherwise is to
assume that the work of sex while it's a
very basic need it's actually one of the
most complex relationships it's the most
complex thing we do so when people is
people are saying oh great we'll have
sex robots and we could put the sex
industry out of business it's kind of
assuming that what I did as an escort is
no more complicated than what Alexa does
when you ask her to refill your birdseed
order
so overall you know uh sex workers are
not and sex in general to kind of misuse
the Rodney Brooks phrase we are not fast
cheap and out of control
[Music]
intense sexual love
in some sense and that's why I like it
it you know in what sense it is evil
it's not this Buddhist smile I love you
all and so on it's okay imagine you are
a happy single man woman whatever
and you have a relatively satisfied love
you meet with friends you have a good
job maybe here and there a one-night
stand life is okay then you fall
passionately with love it will ruin all
your life and it's precisely the
position of I love you you take a
particular human being no and basically
foreign
the commercialization the ownership
of our sexuality
by big business if you like
um uh it's not new Perhaps Perhaps
throughout history you know sexist sex
cells but the degree to which
how we respond to sex
is entirely public controlled and
commercially controlled
seems to me to indicate the death of sex
because so much of sex itself the act
the feelings
um depend on a certain level of autonomy
choice but also intimacy
I have we have the right to keep our
sexual selves away from the prying eyes
of those who want to make money out of
us from social media from that these
very dangerous new things that are
happening of
um putting images on social media
without consent
um when they particularly used by men
against women
um so the the what I would really like
for us to think about is to what extent
intimacy and personal power and choice
of that we all or many of us have sexual
desire is now entirely
stolen from us
and and I find that very problematic I
have a young daughter I have I I have
you know when I talk to my students that
I teach at University and the number of
them and this is really important
because I'm off the generation of the
60s and 70s where sexual Liberation and
the pill supposedly freed us
but what it actually did is what
Jermaine Greer later came to understand
that it made prisoners of us because
for men there was no cost they could
just eat eat meaning have as much sex as
they wanted and expected it and demanded
it and we were not cool unless you
delivered it
that is even a thousand times worse now
young women do not feel they have the
right to refuse it they do not feel they
have the choice I have spoken to so many
young women who have told me that they
are they do things they don't want to do
sexually
because that's what's expected
culturally
so I think we're in a bad place
[Music]
you know I think I'm on this uh panel to
to represent not just a the male
perspective maybe but also a previous
generation uh a generation that did not
grow up with porn uh I mean we found it
but we had to work to find it right you
had to work to find it uh wheel to real
real-to-reels uh and and magazines and
things like that it wasn't just
available at a click of a button uh it
wasn't just everywhere and of course
um no dating apps so I I've never used
one I I have no idea how they work uh I
know I guess to my kids but
um uh you know you actually had as you
said Miriam to muster up the courage uh
to go and ask a girl out and uh for all
of us teen years or at least for most of
us teen years are difficult
and doing that was difficult and hard it
you know I'm I'm tempted to say it's
easier now that you have apps and you
can do it digitally but I don't really
know I suspect it's it's uh it's always
hard courtship and relationships and
finding somebody and figuring out who's
right and who's wrong and the fear of
being rejected and the the building up
the confidence all of that is probably
just as difficult today as it was back
then and and uh we'll probably be that
in in the future so I I don't know to
what extent with regarded dating apps
it's really had an impact uh you know we
always no matter what the issue is we've
always blamed technology and again I'm
dating myself but but people used to
complain bitterly
about kids who are growing up watching
television all the time how awful that
was making them asocial and and uh
Undateable and they never left the house
and never asked anybody for a date and
you know those kids survived somehow and
they they grew up and they they did okay
so uh blaming technology is always an
easy out and I suspect is probably not
true I mean with regard to pawn
Pawn there is a certain
fantasy but there's also an element of
Education again coming from maybe a
generation where we didn't know much
about sex certainly not kind of the kind
of sex that today you can get access to
it at a fingertip and there's a sense in
which that was not very good
um and there's a sex there's a sense in
which porn educates us a little bit
about I mean My Generation was probably
much more repressed and uh about sex and
about preferences and about experiences
and about what we like and what we don't
like and and experimenting and so on and
I think pornography at least exposes us
to the variety and and and teaches us
about what's possible and and maybe
maybe yeah maybe we'll try some of those
poses and it turns out that nah they
don't work but of course there was
always you know I remember uh buying it
you know what was it the Kama Sutra book
right I mean that has many of those
poses and
they don't work you know maybe they walk
but they don't they're not very
pleasurable uh so there's always been a
desire to figure this out and to
uh increase pleasure and find what works
and what doesn't and I think that kind
of explosion is a good thing people
should go out there and and try and and
discover and figure out for themselves
but there is also a downside to porn I
think when you confuse fantasy with
reality
or when you use
you use to replace reality and you you
you you replace uh masturbation and
pornography to replace actual
relationship and actual intimacy and
actual sex or even the one I stand and
I'm not you know I don't want to come
out as I'm against one I my my previous
comment was about that's all you do you
do that all the time right uh you know
once in a while yeah I'm I'm sure it's a
lot of fun
um but if if if you don't want to go out
there you don't want to try you don't
want to actually engage because you're
getting some simulated
replacement through pornography and
through masturbation if it replaces
entity and if it replaces dating and
relationship and ultimately we haven't
talked about love if it replaces love
I don't know what a fulfilled life is if
it doesn't have relationship and love
and sex I I think people are missing out
to the extent that they are becoming
that they're replacing it with some fake
fantasy again it's a there are
opportunities out there and it's it's
it's to learn about those things and it
can be obsessive and it can be and again
it can replace the real thing and that
that's a tragedy if it happens
foreign
[Music]
it's up to each individual person's
preference I think if someone wants to
be totally asexual and live as a monk in
the mountains and that is what makes
them happy they should go and do that
um I personally uh sorry you're on I
love a good Anonymous romp in the hay I
gotta say there's something particularly
fun and exciting about that and I don't
think it has to be uh necessarily a lack
of intimacy if it's someone you don't
know there can be something
especially beautiful about that kind of
connection where it's very fleeting but
um
very intense
um but yeah I think I think people
should really try to get in tune with
what they want and what makes them happy
and I think people
um
some people aren't starting to do more
of that I do think that uh there can be
a lot of online discourse though that
can get really toxic
um where people
um will shame someone for having
different preferences than them and
um there's this uh sense of
righteousness from people who have
different preferences like you should
only have sex within a marriage or like
sex is evil and bad and you should only
do it to make babies I think it's really
unfortunate that people use porn as a
source of sex education
um as a performer
um it's pure fantasy you know we're
shooting these scenes and
um it's you know often two hours for a
short five minute clip
um so there's a lot that's cut out that
you don't see
um I think this country really needs
proper sex education and not just about
the pure mechanics of it
um but about pleasure I do think that
other people from diverse viewpoints
making more important would be great too
so much of it is you know kind of the
same stuff and I get you know it's what
certain people are into but
um I think there could stand to be more
diversity in porn
um I do think as well that dating apps
um have really uh made it difficult for
for people to date in the way that they
used to
um I'm a big fan of dating your friends
and people that you've known for a long
time
um but I think people can get very
anxious about that now and I think
meeting people off of dating apps
um you know is very easy to construct a
fantasy about them or for them to
portray themselves however they want to
be
um and eventually you know you realize
oh my goodness like maybe this is not
actually I didn't know what I was
getting into whereas um when you date
within your friend group obviously there
there's a potential for more drama but
you also kind of know what you're
getting at the end of the day you're
like all right I've seen this person
date five different people before I kind
of know how the relationships went how
they ended what the conflicts were and
so I think
um in a lot of ways it's uh it's a much
more natural way to date on the issue of
porn I wanted to ask you did you is it
your sense oh I'm really interested to
hear what the the rest of the one hour
and 55 minutes that are cut out what
what are we what are we not seeing and
what should we be seeing that maybe
might help people have a more realistic
uh perception of sex rather than sort of
the five minutes as you say that are cut
down from that that perhaps has a a kind
of false representation of what's really
going on but
um is is it that SEC is it the watching
porn and particularly like the fact that
people are watching porn younger and
younger and having access to kind of I
want to say more and more extreme forms
of porn like they're obviously there's
like a gamut of taste but there's also
sort of uh you know sort of the kind of
pornography that I think along just even
10 years ago you would have had to go
really really Niche to find that's now
much more easily accessible to younger
people is that leading in your View to a
kind of uh is that affecting people's
sense of what sex is and their desire to
engage in it I mean how is porn
affecting people's desire sense of
Desire would you say
um this is this is a very interesting
question because I uh I think I
experienced it from both ends both
um uh with my experience escorting and
seeing clients and with my experience as
a performer
um you know we'll be doing crazy
positions in porn that
um this is less something that happens
in my videos but my friends who do very
mainstream porn it's like you know
they'll be like getting their leg up
over there and like you know
um and they'll like get in get it like
to spend like 10 minutes getting into
the perfect position like wiggling
around it's so uncomfortable and then
like all right like we'll shoot let's
roll and then they like shoot like you
know 10 minutes of that and they're like
okay cut and then like you know like all
right now and like let's do this like
it's it's uh it's so unsexy in this way
uh being on one of those sets I mean it
is kind of fun um of course you know
taught to watch people having sex but
it's way less sexy uh than than you
might think
um but when I would have clients
sometimes where I'd just be like oh my
God this guy watches so much porn and
just thinks that's how sex should be and
is never like really
um had like actually good sex like and
it would be such a tragic thing where
you know they'd be sort of like you
could tell they have this checklist
where they're like all right we gotta do
um I don't know how explicit I'm allowed
to get in here missionary then cowgirl
then like I'll finish in doggy style and
like all this stuff I'm like Oh I wanna
you know check all these boxes and get
all these little moments
um and it was just like you're not
really like in the moment when you're
doing that you're not like actually
genuinely uh connecting with the other
person and I think that is something
that people who use porn as a sex
education tool and are not actually
um
connecting with themselves and their
bodies uh tend to get into
[Music]
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Arts
and ideas at iaitv